字幕: Yuta Sugii
校正: Hiroko Kawano
2014年の11月に
東北大学の研究室の
隅っこの方に座ってたんですけど
その時に 突然 僕の携帯に電話が入りました
普段は携帯に出ないんですよ
研究しているときは
でも その時は ちょっと
出てみようと思って出てみたら
気仙沼の方からの電話でした
気仙沼の方からの電話 誰だろう？
「はい 誰ですか？」
「気仙沼の方でデニムを作っている会社です」
「ちょっと 亀井さんに
ご相談があって電話をしました」
「亀井さん 確かいろいろ
自然界の材料を使って
いろんな[物]を作ってましたよね？」
いや はい そうです
ちょうど今もですね 魚の鱗を使って
絶対汚れない表面を作ってるとこでした
「ちょうどよかったです
あの 魚の話なんですよ
実は 私たち 魚で服を作ってしまいました」
[魚から服を作った]
（笑）
なんと！
で この方が 後ほど僕の人生を変える
オイカワデニムの及川洋さんっていう方です
少し このオイカワデニムについて
お話ししましょう
オイカワデニムは
気仙沼の本吉という所にある
小さなデニム会社です
でも しかしこの小さなこの本吉の工場から
メイドインジャパンの
最高級のデニム商品を作り
ロンドン ロシア アメリカ
さまざまな所で名を馳せている
すごい企業だったのです
この人たちは2011年に東北の津波を経験し
今までとは違った新しい商品を作って
地域に貢献出来ないか
ということを考えてたのです
彼らがちょうど私に相談したことは
この気仙沼でよく獲れるカジキマグロ
このカジキマグロ すごく獲れるんですね
年間に数百トン
でもこのカジキマグロの角
この角が 30トンほど
毎年毎年廃棄されてしまう
これを なんとか有効活用出来ないか？
これを何とか自分たちが作っている
デニムに応用できないか？
そしてその成分そのものに
何か有効なものがないのか
といった相談だったんです
で 僕はもう これはすごいチャンスだ
今まで魚の鱗で ちまちまとした
１センチ角にモノをつくってたけど
これで僕も有名になるかもしれないと思って
（笑）
すぐさま気仙沼の方に伺いました
気仙沼の方に伺うと
なんとなんと 僕が想像した以上に
物事が進んでいたんですね
その時 見せられたのが
出来上がったジーパンだったんです
なんと もうできているのか！
（笑）
だったら 僕の出る幕はないのじゃないのかな
と思って落胆したところ
そこで出てきた話がですね
「いや 実は亀井さん
カジキマグロの方の成分の分析は
もちろんお願いしたいんですよ
但し もう一つあります」
気仙沼という所には実は
ホヤ養殖ということをされている
漁師さんがいっぱいます
実はこのホヤ
皆さん見られたことありますか？
こんな形をしています
もう悪魔の実みたいな形ですね
（笑）
でも日本酒と合わせると本当に美味しいんです
このホヤというもの
実は毎年毎年
水揚げ量がどうやら
3000から8000トンらしいんですよ
カジキマグロと１桁違うぞ
そして同じように年間300トン
こちらのホヤの殻 ゴミとして出てしまいます
それが実は 想像以上に地方自治体を
2014年から苦しめていました
今まで漁師さんは自分たちで獲ったホヤ
そこの殻を海に静かに
誰にも見られないように捨てていました
だがしかし そうですね
地方自治体もそれは見逃しません
2015年から「これからホヤの殻は
産業廃棄物として処理してください」
という規則ができたのです
そうすると このホヤを作っている人
ホヤを加工して商品を作っている人たちは
すごく困ってしまいます
それはなぜかというと このホヤの殻
１トンを処理するだけで
１万円の負荷がかかってしまうんですね
それは皆さん聞かれたら
そんなに大きくないコストだろう
と思うかもしれませんが
この１次産業において
そのコストというものは
非常に重い荷なのです
だからこれで何かできないかということを
及川さんに持ち掛けられました
それでここで300トンか
30トンの10倍だなと
これはチャレンジしてみようということで
そこから実際私が一番得意としている
自然から学び それを工学及びプロダクトに
応用しているということを始めました
こちらに見えるのが ホヤの殻です
実は 何日も徹夜をして
やっと分かったことなんですけど
ホヤは海の中で唯一
木と同じ成分を持っている生物らしいです
木はセルロースというもので出来ています
セルロースは私たちの身の回りに
様々な形に姿を変えて
日常の中に溶け込んでいます
例えば今 皆さんが持たれている
TEDxAizuwakamatsu のパンフレット
それも紙で出来ています
で 紙はセルロースで出来ています
ここで考えたのが
セルロースで出来ているということは
紙に出来るはずだ
そして実際調べたところ
このような細かい繊維を持ち
真っ白な和紙を 海の廃棄物から
作ることができました
これは 一見大したことがないように
見えるかもしれないんですけど
海の捨てられてたものが
今までは山の木を切って
わざわざ作ってたものに
変えられるんだという新しい気付きが
ここで生まれたんですね
今この材料というものを
このホヤ由来の繊維単体だけではなくて
再生されたPET繊維であったり
様々なものと折り合わすことによって
プロダクトに使える材料に
姿を変え始めています
PET繊維を加えることによって
防水性も増しますし強度も増します
そうすると単純に紙として使うだけでなくて
バッグの材料であったりとか
あとは服であったりとか
そういったものに
応用ができるようになりました
この及川さんと一緒に始めたプロジェクトで
一番大きな学びとしては
自然の中にあるものを
形そのものとして捉えてはいけない
その背景にある 何で出来ているのか
という所まで物事を深めてみることによって
海と山が繋がり
そして その成果物が私たちの生活の中に
還元されるということが分かりました
私は2011年に 東日本大震災の時に
東北大学で工学を学んでいました
その時 自然界の中にある
様々な造形であったり様々な材料の
最先端の研究をしていたのですが
すぐさま地震があった時に
自分がいかに無力なのかということを
思い知らされてしまいました
ずっとずっと自分が今まで蓄積してきた
知識であったりとか技術
そういったものを何かできないか
何か東北に還元できないか
というモヤモヤを持ちながら
その３年 過ごしていました
その間 自分が得意としていた
材料工学からは離れて
TEDxTohokuという新しいコミュニティ
新しいプラットフォームを作りました
こちらは東北の
さまざまな場面で活躍されている —
東北のさまざまな場面で
課題解決であったり
魅力を活用したアイディアを作られている方々
その人たちをお招きして
東北の方々であったり世界に発信していく
そのことによって
東北の未来を作っていくアイデアを
生み出していき 尚且つ育んでいこうという
そういったプロジェクトでした
そこで私はずっと
このような形で登壇する側ではなく
一人のオーガナイザーとして
そういった方々のサポートをする
立ち位置にいたんですね
でもそれが今度 役割が変わろうとしています
このような素晴らしい方々
片方はそうですね宗教 —
宗教と東北
そして「今後東北の未来が
どう変わっていくのか」
という観点でお話する人だったりとか
「農業とIT化が どう東北の
未来を変えていくか」
または 「海外から来た研究者が
どう福島原発の影響について
成果及びその研究を行うことが出来るか」
そういったいろんな観点で
知見を集めてきたのですが
その知見の中から 尚且つ私自身の
及川さんと一緒に作った
「ホヤから生まれた材料」
その中から 東北の未来において
大事な視点 —
大事な１つの気付きというものは
何なのかということを
この２年考えてきました
それを今回 皆様にすごいシンプルな形で
お伝えしようと思います
[変革の時代]
まずでも大きな前提として
2011年以降 東北地方は
大きな地震 大きな津波
そして福島の原子力発電所の事故を経て
変革の時代に突入しています
これは破壊を経た故に
新しく街であったり
仕組みというものを作り直そう
そういった雰囲気が
この地方全体に漂っています
しばしこの変革の時代と
多くの方が 明治維新を重ねられています
明治維新は皆様ご存知の通り
西洋文化を積極的に日本は取り入れ
列強の一員として 大国として成り上がる
その一つの大きなきっかけとなる出来事でした
これと同じように
新しいものを外から取り入れて
新しい街 新しい地域を作っていこう —
そういった動きが
東北に出てきていると思います
しかし実は 私自身はこのことに関して
少し疑問を持っていました
なぜかというと日本の歴史の中を
よーくよーく見ていくと
この明治維新というものは
大切な日本特有の価値が
少しずつ消えていった
１つのきっかけでもあったからです
歴史の中に もっと深く潜り込んでみますと
その一つの影響を 実際身近に感じた地域
それは福島の会津にあります
だからこそ ここにいる会場の方々は
復興というものと明治維新を繋げて考えると
恐らく私と同じように何か違和感を
持つのではないかという風に思っております
ここでですね 東北の未来というものは
「変化」それだけではないんじゃないか？
求められてるのは変化なのか？
もっと深く言って 変化の「質」が
求められているのではないか？
ではその変化の質 「新しいことをしていく」
それよりも大切な視点って
何なんだろう？というのを
今までの経験から考えてみました
[豊かな未来]
東北にとって
それは押し付けられた未来ではなくて
一番豊かな未来っていうのは何なのか？
それを考えるために一番重要な視点
これは「NEW」ではなく「FRESH」
この一言に尽きるんじゃないかな
というのが私の意見です
今まで 復興する過程で
この東北という土地は 外を見て
いかに新しいものを この土地に
もたらせるか？という
そういう視点で考えてきました
でも実はその「見た目の新しさ」ではなくて
「本質的な新しさ」を
発見するために「新しい視点」
これこそが東北の未来を考えるために
非常に重要となります
この「新しい視点」
それはどのようにしたら
培っていけるのでしょうか？
それは単純です
外から新しいものを取り組む前に
まず一人一人が 東北の自然
東北の課題 東北の街に繰り出て
「これは面白いな」
「これは何で出来ているんだろう？」
「これ何かに生かせないか？」
そういったおもしろさ 不思議に感じる —
今まで問題だと思ってたものを
ホヤの和紙と同じように チャンスに変える
こういったことが必要となると思います
ですので今回 私のプレゼンテーションで
唯一覚えててほしいのは
地域にとって一番幸せな未来を作るためには
新しさではなく新しい視点
この新しい視点をいかに培うかということを
意識して欲しいということです
ありがとうございます
（拍手）